[Music]
hi there this is a comprehensive paper
review on the paper improving intrinsic
exploration with language abstractions
this is a very cool paper because it
combines a language and the information
that is in language with reinforcement
learning specifically the problem of
exploration i don't want to tell you too
much more right now because we're going
to dive into the paper in just a bit so
this video will explain in detail what
is in the paper how the method works
what they're doing so by the end of this
video you should have a really good idea
of what's in the paper in the next video
published tomorrow there's going to be
an interview with the authors of the
paper which is very very cool it's super
valuable and i was very happy to
to host this interview so i hope you
draw some value out of either one of
these videos hopefully both as always
thank you very much for watching thanks
to everyone who likes and comments and
supports in any way it's really cool to
be able to do these things and i'll see
you around bye-bye
hi there today we're looking at
improving intrinsic exploration with
language abstractions by researchers of
stanford university university of
washington meta ai and university
college london this paper on a high
level uses language to facilitate
intrinsic exploration that is when in
the face of a very sparse environment a
reinforcement learning agent has to come
up with its own goals in order to make
progress so the intrinsic exploration or
intrinsic motivation refers to the fact
that uh the
there's an additional reward that we
give to the agent just for attaining
let's say new states novel things in the
environment now turns out that that's
not super duper easy because not all new
things are equal and especially let's
say there is a random component in the
environment um then you know that's
going to be new every time yet it might
not be interesting so how you go about
this is quite a challenge it's clear
that we need something like this in
sparse sparse rewards environment but
how exactly to do it is still
still challenging this paper adds
language to the mix and argues that
language descriptions could be one such
source of novel of
indicators of novel states so we're
gonna go through the paper let me know
what you think um in the comments
definitely and yeah let's dive in
so
they say they want to solve these these
complex long horizon tasks with sparse
rewards and as i already said that is
not really
a picnic for reinforcement learning
agents usually those need very tight
very dense rewards in order to work and
that's why we give these intrinsic
rewards for exploration
and that is is encouraging the agent
even in the absence of rewards to go out
and explore things and do new things and
we hope that through the exploration at
some point it will learn the skills or
it would encounter something that will
that will actually give true reward
so
they correctly claim there is a design
choice on how to measure exploration
uh and a an implicit like a common
answer that the agent should be rewarded
for attaining novel states in the
environment but that is as we already
said quite difficult to actually
implement for example states can look
cosmetically different but have the same
underlying semantics and thus not be
truly novel
so
the two fundamental challenges for
intrinsic exploration they uh
they list here is first how can we
reward true progress in the environment
over meaningless exploration
second how can we tell when a state is
not just superficially but semantically
novel
and that's where they add in language
they say well if we had language
describing the states then certainly um
for example here we have language
that describes the the state um
here the the language description says
in what direction uh indicating that you
can go in a couple of directions or do
something in a couple of directions uh
you see here a crystal wand that means
there's something to pick up so when you
don't have this message that might be an
indication that the state is
meaningfully different namely it doesn't
have the crystal wand so
as you can see these authors imagine
that if we had a language description of
the environment that could give us an
indication of when something is novel
and
when something is just the same but
looks a little bit different
they say language obviously has strong
priors over the features and behaviors
needed for meaningful interaction and
skill acquisition and that's just a
matter of fact that language has been
developed to communicate things that are
useful to humans um and they also say
correctly that you know you can describe
with language very particular things
such as move left or very abstract
things like acquire the amulet and
defeat the wizard although the
one of the abstraction here comes from
the end but still defeat the wizard is a
very very abstract thing
now
as we
already said what they're going to do
here is they're going to look at these
environments at these reinforcement
learning environments so there's mini
grid on the left and in mini grid i
believe the agent here you're the that's
the the uh red triangle
and the agent is supposed to i think go
to the keys get the keys open the doors
and eventually get the final reward that
is somewhere on the map these are
procedurally generated so it always kind
of looks different and
that's one challenge because
if you have to make sequences of actions
like go over here get that key go to the
door
and then go further and get the reward
that is a sequence of actions that is
unlikely to happen by by chance right to
stumble over the key and to stumble over
the door and to stumble over the reward
you know the amount of times you're
going to try randomly until that's the
case
yes is staggering and therefore
something like q learning which just
requires on random exploration is going
to sir almost certainly fail right here
but this is one of the environments
which is a challenging environment that
they they pick up and that has these
language descriptions or i think in this
one they add the language descriptions
but in any case this is not about
language models or anything like this
they assume that they have a function
which they call l
the language annotator that takes in a
state takes in and gives you the
description and they just assume they
have an oracle that does that so for the
environments they do test they actually
have that um
and
so in in mini hack here this is even
part of the game right uh in mini hack
you will always get a message like this
to to every step that you do in
almost most of them most of these states
have such a description available so
again there's this function l which in
this case is just the game engine it
takes in the state and it gives you back
the
description so
um if you
you could guess here that we might learn
this language descriptor right we might
even initialize it with a language model
we can use something like clip or
something like this
this is certainly in the future work
they list this but not here here we
assume we have this oracle now what can
we do once we have such a language
description well we can use it for
exploration
so there is a little bit of of mathy
math right here which we're going to
skip um
essentially this just discusses that
yeah they have this annotator l that
produces these natural language
descriptions
and
then they add an intrinsic reward
to to this and now we're going to look
at what the intrinsic reward is
so they're going to take
two different
in like two different algorithms that
are already made for intrinsic
motivation and they're going to augment
them with language the reasoning behind
it is that those two algorithms the one
is called amigo the other one we'll get
to in a second
they're already kind of state of the art
in this domain so what they say is if we
add language to those and we can get a
better result then that kind of shows
the usefulness of language of the
language descriptions
so we're going to look at these
algorithms briefly remember these
algorithms aren't by this paper this
paper is how to add language to them
so amigo
the adversarially motivated intrinsic
goals trains a student and a teacher so
there is a teacher that generates goals
and then the student is just a goal
conditioned policy
the goal is as we said provided by the
teacher so the student is the real
reinforcement learner but the student is
simply conditioned on some goal that's
provided by the teacher
it is not it doesn't try to solve the
actual problem uh it solves the the goal
that the teacher gives it i mean it
probably gets reward
when it accidentally also fulfills the
true reward goal but it does get
intrinsic reward when it fulfills the
goals set by the teacher
now the goal is set by the teacher
that's the trick obviously right here
the teacher policy is quite smart um
the teacher policy takes in the state of
the student so it looks at you know
where is the student
and it needs to now decide what do i do
um what kind of goal do i give this
student on the top left here you see
this in
in in this mini grid environment the
teacher
is this network or this function right
here it gives a coordinates that the
student has to get to
and then these coordinates as you can
see they're ah i'm not sure if those are
the actual coordinates but whenever the
student actually reaches them so it
provides the goal to the student when
the student reaches it it gets reward
so that's it there is also a notion of a
difficulty threshold that difficulty
threshold is uh
it increases during training so the idea
is that at the beginning the teacher
wants to suggest kind of easy goals and
then as time progresses the teacher has
to learn essentially how to make the
goals harder and harder and
by
making the goals harder the student
essentially has a curriculum of harder
to reach skills so the teacher should
kind of learn to propose more hard goals
so i think that the work here is
definitely done mostly by this teacher
network and the challenges in any case
there is this difficulty threshold this
difficulty threshold is increased
linearly during training
and the student no sorry the teacher the
teacher is given a positive reward
if it proposes goals that take the
student more than t star time steps to
complete and a negative reward for goals
that are completed sooner or never
completed within the finite time horizon
so it also can't go impossible or it
can't go too hard it needs to go exactly
as hard the student
reaches the goal which means even even
if it's a possible goal it can't go too
hard for the current student
it needs to essentially propose goals
that are just outside the outside the
abilities of the current student
so that that zone of proximal
development is kind of formalized in
this teacher
that's amigo
the other so how do we add
how do we add language to that we saw
that usually the teacher supposes or
proposes coordinates for the student to
get to
now if we have language descriptions for
every state so every state the student
finds itself in there is a language
description the teacher can simply
output a language description of a state
right in this case the these are
formulated as um
as kind of instructions right but
remember they are just descriptions
as as far as i can tell of of the state
uh it is more evident in the mini hack
environment right so these these are
just descriptions of the state whatever
the game would output
if you're in this state and the teacher
simply proposes these so it just says
well here is a goal for you try to get
to a state where the language descriptor
outputs that
so that those are the goals that the
teacher can choose
um
where are we yep
so they we don't have xy goals but we
have natural language goals the student
is rewarded if it reaches a state with
the natural language description that
the teacher outputs
easy enough so how does the teacher do
this
it selects goals from the set of
possible language descriptions in the
environment now
initially these are unknown so the
teacher doesn't know yet what the
environment has in store because again
we don't assume let's say extra
information we need to get out
everything of the environment
therefore
as we go through the environment we
collect more and more of these goals and
these are the goals that the teacher can
choose
the teacher maintains a running set of
goals that is updated as the student
encounters new state descriptions
the teacher has
this move to language they say creates a
challenge not only must the teacher
choose which a goal to give to the
student
it must also determine which goals are
achievable
and that's why they train two different
networks there is a policy network which
produces the distribution over goals
given a student's state and a grounding
network which predicts the probability
that a goal is likely to be achieved in
the first place so remember these
environments they're procedurally
generated so every time the student is
every new episode i believe that's how
it works the student is placed in some
environment that it has essentially
never seen before so now the teacher
takes that in and it produces two things
it looks it looks at this environment
produces two things from the set of
goals that it has it picks one that it
wants to propose
that needs to be
right so for it cannot always do the
same and that's the interesting part
right here so if the green door is over
here go to the green door might be very
easy in one environment but very hard in
the other environment when i first read
this i thought well if you know if the
teacher knows no goals at the beginning
and it only collects these goals that
the student student encounters over the
course of the episode we're still kind
of relying on random exploration of the
student right because any goal it hasn't
achieved yet cannot be proposed whereas
in the original x y coordinate i can i
believe at least i can just propose any
x y coordinate like get to that
however since this is procedurally
generated you might imagine that a
student encounters like the green door
in one environment where it's very easy
it essentially just stumbles
upon it and then the in the next one
that's kind of a bit more challenging to
reach
so we are still good on collecting goals
the other network it does is this
grounding network so the ground let's
call that gd the grounding network it it
gets the initial state
and it
proposes it checks which of the goals
are even possible to reach so these are
two slightly different uh targets the
policy or let's call that
poll
well
okay
the policy network um
wants to propose goals which it finds
challenging enough right
for the student to fulfill the grounding
network wants to check which of the
goals are even reachable in the first
place
the
the grounding network specifically is
trained as this multi-class they say a
multi-label binary cross entropy loss
which i find to be a weird term but okay
but essentially
it's
given the initial state of an episode we
ask the grounding network to predict the
first language description encountered
along this trajectory where t is the
minimum t such that there is a
description at all
so we're training
we're training the grounding network to
predict the first language description
term against all the other term in its
encountered goals this is kind of like a
contrastive loss so the that first goal
is certainly reachable from the initial
state and we simply take all the other
ones as kind of a negatives for that for
that first one
and uh exactly so the second one can be
seen as noisily generating negative
samples of start state and unachieved
description now
now
yeah based on the set of descriptions
known to the teacher now this seems a
bit weird right to train the grounding
network like this
um like what about the second text
description that was encountered that's
certainly reachable too no
at least i would
at least i would uh
i would guess so
this is really necessary
or maybe this here
maybe this here should be over goals
that
weren't encountered in the episode at
all right
but
this seems quite weird to only take the
first encountered language description
as a positive example of this grounding
network
further and let's go into criticism
right after we conclude here
they say to summarize the teacher
training training the teacher involves
three steps updating the running set of
descriptions seen in the environment
that's collecting the goals essentially
learning the policy network based on
whether the student achieved the goals
proposed by the teacher okay that's the
same as the original amigo and third
learning the grounding network by
predicting descriptions encountered from
initial states
okay well
the
this description here i can agree with i
don't i just don't see why only the
first is taken as the
um as the positive sample
so what what are we doing right here
uh
and why
what i find weird is that this grounding
network has to exist at all right in the
original description i don't know if
these things are generated
if these certainly all the coordinates
exist right somewhere but they're not
necessarily reachable either
for the original amigo it seems weird
that the policy network itself
whose goal it is to propose a goal that
is just outside of the reach essentially
of the student
couldn't itself make the determination
of whether a state is reachable at all
because the original omigo network seems
to be perfectly capable of making that
determination for a set of coordinates
right
so
it might you know there is a difference
in that the
something that go to the green door
there might be not a green door at all
in the environment but it seems it seems
a bit weird to split this stuff up into
a different
into different networks and it tells me
maybe they tried it first and that
didn't work so they had to throw in kind
of another loss
which is
is kind of a bit
just a bit um annoying but you know if
it works with the extra loss then okay
here you can see again we have the amigo
teacher first that's the grounding
network what is even possible in this
environment then it that is related to
the policy network or multiplied by the
output of the policy network policy
network predicts goals that the student
in its current state
could reach but not under the threshold
all the while we add new goals we train
the grounding network on states that
were actually reached during
what language was achieved during the
episodes we take the other ones as
negatives
and then lastly
the policy network is trained like amigo
now there is a typo here i believe i
believe because here it says the reward
is given if the goal is achieved in less
than t star steps but i believe it
should be more
i believe this should be more
because that's what it says in the text
um
yeah so
that's that's that
um
yeah i don't know why by the split so
the important difference as well is that
the policy network is trained
essentially with reinforcement learning
right it's uh
it's a i guess an actor critic framework
and it's trained on the action that it
actually output like in classic
reinforcement learning fashion yet the
grounding network seems to be more
achieved in a classic supervised sense
just as an online classifier
i'm not sure if they have done ablations
i haven't seen
the ablation of what the el amigo does
without the grounding network but it
would be interesting to see
the second
so here you can see how they add
language right they add language by
essentially replacing that
teacher-student relationship where the
teacher proposes goals in coordinate now
the teacher proposes goals in language
so that's the novelty here the other one
the other algorithm is this novel d
algorithm so the novelty algorithm
is a little bit different
it defines intrinsic reward to be the
difference in novelty between a state
and the previous state so there's this
notion of novelty
and we're not going to take that as
as itself like we're not going to take
the novelty and and
and give the agent a reward simply for
achieving whatever we call novelty right
and we can define novelty in whatever
way we choose
what we do is we do we give the reward
if the agent transitions from a state of
low novelty to a state of high novelty
okay and so that's the that's this thing
right here uh the max with zero is so
that this cannot be negative so we don't
penalize going from high novelty states
to low novelty states because
you know sometimes that is necessary
um
and
we also only give that reward if a state
is encountered for the first time so
here the agent is encouraged to find new
states because it only gets rewards when
it encounters new states and it is
especially encountered to
find
to find new states that are a
significant increase in novelty
from the previous states
this is this is one
i guess one
way
what this avoids i guess is to get stuck
in this loop yeah let's say it's like
you're in you're in an environment right
and uh you're in an environment and then
here
is like a random just some random thing
people usually
they uh they say there's a tv
with static on like just kind of like
or there's a bunch of leaves flowing
around or something like this and
the agent that is just going for a
novelty would just indefinitely stare at
it and this prevents it because um
whatever you call novelty if you call
this novel like a tv with static because
it's essentially a random signal so it's
super duper novel
however you wouldn't get a reward for
consecutively looking at the tv because
you would already be in an equally novel
state going to a new novel state and
that will give you no reward at all so
you're encouraged actually to go away
from the tv go somewhere else where you
can transition from a low novelty to a
single high novelty state
all right so
yeah
what they say is in the first term the n
is the novelty that this quantity
describes the difference in novelty
between successive stage which is
clipped
larger than zero this is written a
little bit weird this quantity here
refers to the first term
not to this thing right here this thing
is just a an explanation of what's in
the term
um so n is the novelty and the reward is
the difference in novelty
the second term right only if we
encounter it for the first time
and
how does this thing
how does this thing track novelty this
is an interesting concept um how do we
do no like how do we
know if a state is novel sometimes it is
sufficient they say to track exact state
visitation counts but obviously as soon
as the environment gets larger and a bit
more complex this is not possible
anymore so what do we do we use this
random network distillation and i have
to say i have never heard of this and it
seems quite smart so what we do is we
have a state again so your agent is here
there's a bunch of walls and so on what
we do is we
we
have a random neural network now that's
always the same but it is
essentially random so we take the state
we feed it through the random neural
network we get out some vector just some
vector because it's a randomly
initialized fixed neural network
it's going to be
some some kind of embedding of that um
not a useful one but just some sort of
an embedding and then what we do is we
train a
uh what what do they call it
we train an estate embedding network so
let's call that e
we train embedding again this one takes
this in and it tries to predict this
vector right it tries to predict it now
obviously it doesn't it can't see the
weights of this neural network otherwise
this would be quite useless um
but it tries to predict this vector and
it is trained so the e is trained with
back propagation uh while the blue one
is fixed
now the logic here is that if i
encounter a new state right so here's my
new state agent is here there's just one
wall here there's like a door here
i put it through both oops i put it
through both of these
new color
i put it through
[Music]
hey
yo
i put it through this one and i put it
through this one
and then
i get a vector here
and i get a vector
here i look at the error between the two
right so what's what's the difference
if
the error is small i can safely assume
that i have seen states like this before
because if the error is small it means
that this thing has learned to match
this thing
for some kind of similar state right
we know that neural networks generalize
well if the train if they have training
data in the same vicinity of the data
that you want to test on therefore if
the states are quite close that means
the outputs are quite close that's a
property of random neural networks if
you don't change the states much it
depends a little bit on parameterization
but essentially if you change the input
a little bit the neural network's output
will change a little bit
and um
therefore if you've encountered states
like this before this e would be trained
on those states would actually learn to
match the blue net fixed network's
output and therefore the distance here
would be small however if the state is
super novel that would not have been
like anything in the training data and
therefore this e network would make a
large mistake um when trying to predict
a vector and from that mistake right
here because that's you have that at
inference time right you can uh
determine whether something is novel
there's a bunch of caveats but since
this paper isn't about novelty itself
i'm not gonna i'm gonna reserve that for
another time
so what do we do it to add language
that's this paper now we add an
additional exploration bonus
based on novelty defined according to
the natural language description of
states
so
again we it is simply a repetition of
the formula we have some sort of a
notion of novelty of a linguistic
description
and we give the reward if the novelty of
the new state is higher than novelty of
the old state for whatever definition
and only the first time we encounter it
so they say nl is the novelty of the
description l
as measured by a separately
parameterized random network
distillation network encoding the
description so presumably other than
inputting states now every state also
has a language description so language
description here a language description
here we have a separate network
that a separate random network that we
can put them through
and
we can
we also have a separate
embedding network let's call that e l
the language embedding network and we do
the exact same thing with the language
as we did with the states themselves
we try to train this el in order to
predict to match the predictions of the
random network if at inference time
the two match closely we assume that
this is like something we've seen in the
training data and otherwise it's novel
so here you can see
they say we keep the original
exploration bonus as language rewards
may be sparse so they they add both the
intrinsic reward is the original one
that is just about the state and the new
one with a hyper parameter
and here
i think it becomes clear
what for me the biggest criticism of
this paper is and that
i i think so they make the point that
well you know language helps and if you
if you look at the experiments they say
linguistic exploration outperforms
non-linguistic exploration that's one of
their experimental findings you can look
at the results although the confidence
intervals like this is just
reinforcement learning i get it but yo
you had to work hard to make those
you know to make these overall intervals
not not overlap um that that is
you know good job but still
um the noise in these environments is
quite significant
and linguistic exploration excels in
larger environments which you can
imagine right because in larger
environments they might be also more
complex environments and therefore just
state abstractions themselves might not
um be the best one
but my criticism here is that
essentially they add extra data right so
it's not like
linguistic exploration outperforms
non-linguistic exploration it's hey uh
the environment actually has this data
right here and no one we know this one
no one's used that so people just have
used the image or whatnot and the
actions and the rewards and there's this
extra data what if we use this extra
data oh we get better wow and the data
is obviously very good because
it's made by humans and and the game
creators have essentially so the game
creators
know which states are equal right they
code the game and i
in the same vein they produce these
language descriptions so the language
descriptions are almost like a little
bit of a view into the internal state
of the game code itself right even if
that weren't the case language obviously
is is quite powerful but
i i get their argument that you know
language gives you abstraction yada yada
yada and so on um
however i think the gains here aren't
languages better than you know not
language because i don't think it's a
necessarily a fair comparison it is you
know
adding more stuff adding more
information especially really good
really high quality information like
they have
is better
than non not adding that information
now obviously
it matters what they do with the
information um
but
uh yeah i think a lot of the gains
simply come from the fact that they add
something on top
so um
not to say like they for example in
el amigo they drop the original teacher
right but in this
in this in this novel d they don't even
drop the original intrinsic exploration
yeah
so
you know it's essentially really extra
data that they add
what is interesting is that they analyze
the curricula that emerge right it's
given that it's language you can you
have a pretty good idea of what's
happening over time and
they have these nice analyses right here
where for example first the teacher
proposes open the door
before it proposes open the colored door
so see here is a variable that holds a
color
so you can see that
the teacher first proposes the easier
goal of opening any door and then it
proposes a lot of opening the opening
colored doors it then discovers keys
going to the keys picking up keys uh
then going next to the door with the key
and after it goes through the door it
picks up the ball which is the final the
final goal so you can see clearly that
as the training progresses the teacher
gives more and more complex goals and
that is is kind of true it's true for l
amigo and this novel d it is not that
true in all the
environments um for the for the net hack
environment i believe it's a little bit
more they call it a little bit more
exploratory uh in that they it it just
tries to explore a lot of stuff which is
also good right that that is
it doesn't need to be progressive right
as long as the teacher encourages the
student to you know do this and now okay
now you're really good at that so i
can't essentially propose that anymore
because you'll you'll fulfill it in less
than the threshold time steps now you
know do something else now do something
else and do something else again these
aren't the descriptions right
it's
yeah this these are these are meant to
be descriptions not instructions so this
here i guess is a is a better again a
better example um so you want to reach a
state that has the description of there
is a staircase up here right
so you just tell the student please
reach us any state with that description
and you can see how this develops which
is pretty cool
the last thing they do is something that
i also find
very very interesting in that um
even though
right even though
as far as i understand and i think they
say this somewhere they don't use
pre-trained language models or anything
like this in here
they do
obviously output language and so on so
they need some sort of language model
but they don't use they don't make use
of any pre-training on any external data
or anything like this yet still the
semantics of the language seem to be
captured a little bit for example they
do this experiment where they replace
all the language goals with unique
identifiers so go to the red door would
just become token one go to the blue
door would become token two so now there
is no shared sub strings so the the
model um cannot generalize from this go
to the door um construction and sort of
generalize the skills or or generalize
the reachability estimate of the goal
um
the result is one what goals perform
quite competitively which is good right
so
that
lends more credence to what i say like
this is just this is extra data all
right
um
then the second thing is the l amigo is
better able to exploit semantics with a
more significant improvement in
aggregate performance over the one hot
goals in contrast to l novel d which
shows less of a difference so at least
one of the methods is actually able to
exploit these semantics in the language
and that is a promising outlook if we
now want to go ahead and you know use
something like pre-trained language
models in these or something like clip
uh to even
to even get the description out of the
state itself that would be that would be
really cool or some sort of a some sort
of a
clip modified for reinforcement learning
so we don't need to rely on environments
which are
which have this language description
already built in because
very very few
do right and it seems to be
it seems to be quite hard to get
honestly right if we want to train a
good model for that that is that is
challenging right if
let's say atari or so
um
very challenging you either need to
collect labeled data for you know
describing atari states which itself is
really hard and if you let three humans
do it you're going to get three
completely different descriptions and at
that point we're going to need these
large language models because the larger
language models need to be able to tell
well these two
wildly different descriptions are
actually meaning the same thing right
and how much of a gain
at that point is still left uh
when all this noise comes on top of the
learned description models and of the
infra inferring whether two language
descriptions are the same or not
whether or not there's still an actual
difference there to
to like el amigo and amigo
remains to be seen right in this paper
here
uses a lot of oracles right
to to get its data
which you know is which is uh
fine for research but it's not
necessarily means that this is going to
be a practical thing in the future
so
yeah um they say this though they
criticize themselves i fairly well i
think uh say they want to alleviate the
restriction
on oracle language annotations perhaps
by using learned state description
models
yep exciting extension would be to
propose abstract goals which is also
pretty cool and again something where
large language models can come in and
help
uh pre-trained ones even right you don't
even have to train them and um yeah
using pre-trained well okay that's
stuck in my mind from reading it the
last time pre-trained models to imbue
semantics into the model beforehand they
say would also be pretty interesting
among a lot of other things they also
criticize the noisiness and
and so on so that was it for the paper
overview um
let me know what you think about this
paper i find it to be pretty interesting
and i think it's a really cool cool idea
um
and if we can extend this to not use
oracles i would be super happy and i
think
this essentially is how humans also
learn a lot of times
by talking about things by talking about
goals and so on language does provide a
really good abstraction for these types
of stuff yeah let me know what you think
in the comments leave a like if you do
and i'll see you around bye
[Music]
you